foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar tips and
tricks for successful multiplexing IHC
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more please visit
thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you can also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
DARPA and Sarah swap darpan is a
neuroscientist and microscopist with a
doctorate degree in biology at hnb
garwell University and a master of
science in biotechnology from ddu gork
Port University
for a complete biography on today's
speaker click their name in the
presenters window at the top right of
your screen
darpan you may now begin your
presentation
hi thank you for thank you very much for
attending today's webinar on Multiplex
ISC my name is what I have been working
with Thermo Fisher since scientific
since 2021 as a technical application
scientist
supporting evos microscopes and Thermo
Fisher cell analysis product portfolio
if you want to detect multiple Targets
in your IC experiment but don't know how
to design this experiment or you are
doing it but you are having having some
doubts this presentation is for you
what is Multiplex immunohistochemistry
it's a it's a technique that allows
multiple biomarkers to be simultaneously
detected in a single tissue section
which help us to illustrate the spatial
relationship among individual cell types
it could be three blacks four plaques or
more
so either you are doing
immunohistochemistry experiment like a
single Plex or a multiplex experiment
the first three steps like sample
preparation
anti-generate level and the blocking
backgrounds are same the main difference
comes at the fourth step which is Target
detections here you should be very
careful on choosing the primary
antibodies secondary antibody diet
choice and potential amplification
methods finally sample is mounted with
an appropriate mounting media and
analyze samples on a microscope with the
appropriate Imaging softwares
this is an example image of three Plex
immunohistochemistry essay on adult
Mouse retina tissue using new n and
beta3 tubulin antibodies the samples
were counter-stained using dappy in
vitrogen prolonged glass anti-fed
reagent is used as a mountain and the
image are captured using evos m5000
microscope
this is an example fourplex image of
human tonsil tissue labeled with Ki 67
pen cytokeratin smooth muscle actin and
counter stain with her stye prolonged
glass anti-fed reagent is used as a
mountain and images were captured using
m7000 automated microscope
so before deciding uh before starting
your Multiplex immunohistic chemistry
experiment it's very important to know
the Imaging platform and the
quantification techniques that you are
going to use so if you are doing a four
Plex essay you can use in vitrogen
inverse m7000 or it was m5000 and you
can use fluorophores red blue green
and far red fluorophores or near
infrared fluorophores for in our evos
m5000 and it was m7000 scopes
now let's talk about sample preparation
which is very crucial step for
successful immunohistochemistry it is
very important to prefix animal tissue
by using paraphernal dehyde and avoid
glutal dehyde if you are using
fluoresense Imaging as it will increase
Auto fluorescence next you have to do
the tissue embedding for either paraffin
processing or cryogen processing but
make sure to avoid folds in your tissues
bubbles in your tissues or make sure and
make sure the tissue is properly adhered
on the slides if that it does not happen
what happen in the when you are
performing in the histochemistry you
will notice tissue tearing or disruption
and you will lose the important spatial
information from that tissue
the third step is post fixation if you
think the prefixation is not enough or
you have using the fresh Frozen tissue
you can post face your tissue using
gluten using for multihyde or
coagulating reagents like methanol or
acetones
the the fourth fourth and more very
important step is permeabilization it's
required if the antibody needs to access
to to go inside of the cells to detect
our data antigen for example
intracellular proteins and cytoplasmic
epitopes of transmembrane protein you
can use permeabilizations uh detergents
like tritonix saponine or twin 20 or you
can use solvents like acetones for
permeabilizations
if anti if formalization is not enough
you can perform antigen retrieval to
expose antigen binding sites for
antibody labeling using uh by by heating
samples in a citrate buffer or using
proteolytic enzymes like pepsin pronase
proteinase K or combinations of both
if you have done immunohistochemistry
before you have must have noticed that
some samples have high flow High
autofluorescence
Auto fluorescence may be because of
aldehyde fixation autoflosis also comes
from paraffin processing and sometimes
it comes from natural sources like
aldehyde vitamins lipofusin plant
protein and pigments
so what you will do to reduce this
autofluorescence you can use chemical
treatments like sodium borohydrate
treatment
you can use quenching methods like you
using cupric sulfate Evans Blue Sudan
black you can quench the autoflow since
or you can use in vitrogen thyramidine
super boost amplification kits to
amplify over autofluorescence
or you can use digital removal digitally
remove the auto fluorescence using in
vitrogen Cellar software or you have a
or in your lab if you have a spectral
deconvolution system that can also be
used to digitally removed autoflow since
from your sample
to reduce background signals and false
positive it's very important to use
protein based components or serums to
bind to structures that would otherwise
attracts antibody
uh there are different type of blockers
available like normal serum you can use
protein solution like BSA gelatin
non-fat dry milk or you can use
pre-formulated blocking commercial
blocking buffers
sometime at additional blocking steps
are reading required if you are using
amplification steps in that cases you
need endogenous biotin endogenous
peroxidase and Indigenous phosphatase
blocking steps
please make sure when you are doing a
blah blog when you are using blocking
your samples to check the negative
control and the positive controls with
various blocking reagent and choose the
uh choose the right blocking buffer that
yields highest signal to noise ratio
make sure your blocking reagent does not
have any any component which will
interfere with your your essay suppose
you are using uh biotin binding protein
and and you and you want to use dry milk
for that dry milk contains biotin so in
that case uh
dry milk is not the right blocking
buffer for your experiment
for optimal essay I I would highly
recommend that use the same locking
buffer for diluting your primary
antibodies
with this background let's discuss how
to plan Multiplex ISC experiments
first you need to choose the right
primary antibody and second you have to
choose the right fluorophore and image
settings I will talk about this bullet
points in my later sites and this in and
I'm going to discuss these bullet points
in in details
so let's start the primary antibody is
the most important aspect of
immunohistochemistry
if you are doing a IC experiment make
sure to choose the antibody which is
tested for immunostrochemistry
experiment make sure the antibody is
species passivity of the primary
antibody decide do you need a polyclonal
antibody polyclonal antibody will bind
to multiple multiple sites on your
talgene or on your target while
monoclonal antibody will bite only to
single epitope sites So based on your
experimental needs how much specificity
you want you have to decide between the
polyclonal and the monoclonal antibody
make sure to consider the clone of the
antibody because some clone of the
antibody will work better on some
specific tissues So based on your tissue
you have to choose the right clone of
the antibody and avoid same species
staining
here the subtype of primary import
antibody is very important so if you are
using uh using a IGG 190 bodies you have
to make sure the secondary antibody
which you are going to use is igg1 uh
for a multiplexing experiment make sure
the antibody is within the stability
period and stored properly
you can go to our Thermo Fisher
Scientific antibody research tool and
you can check these things like you can
check the con the application of a
primary antibody is it validated for ICF
ISC application or not you can go to
Advanced verification tab to see the
antibody specificity data you can go in
the conjugate tab to see if the antibody
is already conjugated to the fluorophore
or if you need the unconjugated primary
antibody
uh it's very important to optimize your
primary antibody protocol commercial
antibodies comes with the protocol but
the optical optimal condition must be
determined emphatically with every
sample make sure to tighter the antibody
concentration you can use the starting
point which is recommended by the car by
which is recommended but make sure to
tighter different concentration of the
antibody to get the appropriate
concentration optimize the incubation
time try different blocking solutions to
reduce non-specific binding and if you
are using
intracellular proteins try make sure to
use antigen retrieval if you don't
follow these steps what will go wrong if
suppose you have you use too much
antibody you will see the over
saturation of the signals with the
correct antibody tighter you you will
see appropriately appropriately labeling
in ask appropriate labeling without
signing
non-specific binding
for a multiplex analysis it's very
important to use the approbe right title
of your antibody
a lot of the same precaution uh is
required for choosing the secondary
antibody as
make sure the specificity of the primary
antibody is created avoid same species
staining sub type of antibody is very
important so it should match with the
primary antibody
make sure the antibody is within the
stability period and is stored properly
and choose the appropriate conjugate
like dye biotin or enzyme based on the
relative Target abundance
as with primary antibodies secondary
antibodies should always be optimized
one protocol does not fit all tighter
antibody concentration optimize
incubation time
make sure to use the same blocking
solution for diluting the antibody which
you use for primary antibody if you
don't follow these these things it will
lead to non-specific binding of
antibodies cross reactivity and bleed
through issues
based on relative Target abundance
sometimes we have to use different
labeling strategy for our ISC experiment
Thermo Fisher offer variety of secondary
antibodies for example direct conjugates
standard secondary labeling primary or
secondary antibodies everything biotin
amplification enzyme amplification or
you can use combinations or both I will
go in details about different labeling
strategies in my later slides
first let's talk about how to decide
appropriate labeling strategy it depends
on how abundant is your target if your
target is highly expressed and you want
to Multiplex with the same primary
species you can use direct conjugates or
primary antibodies if you don't want to
Multiplex with the same primary species
you can either use secondary antibodies
or you can use direct conjugates if if
your target is medium expressing
the best choice is secondary antibodies
if your target is low abundant you can
use streptavidine avidine antibody
conjugates and for low exp very low
expressing targets thymidine signal
amplification kit is the right option
a prime direct conjugates of primary
antibody it's a in this the primary
antibody is conjugated to a fluorescence
dye or the attack that can be detected
directly without the need of secondary
labeling there are various advantage of
using using direct conjugate the you can
use same spaces and same isotype
antibodies on same tissue staining type
time is much shorter but
they are disadvantage also like only
about half of the stand intensity of the
standard secondary labeling if Utah if
your target is low abundant you can't
use direct conjugate antibodies on there
and because of the size of the complex
it will also lead to a penetration issue
in the image on the right you can see
that the protocol is very
straightforwards like four step process
fix and paramelize the tissue block with
the appropriate serum in qubit with the
primary conjugated antibody and mount
the cover slip
secondary antibody detection in this
it's a two-step detection process where
unconjugated primary antibody is
detected with the dye conjugated
secondary antibody against the species
and isotype of the primary
it's a most commonly used technique
labeling is sufficiently bright and we
have large selection of commercially
available fluorescent secondary
antibodies but it has a disadvantage
because protocol time is longer as
compared to direct conjugates you have a
you have an additional steps of first
video bind with the primary antibody
then the second step is binding with the
secondary antibody so it's a longer
protocol time with Multiplex labeling
there are chances of cross reactivity
and and there is also a potential for
additional non-specific background
everything biotin amplification While
most essays are fine using a die
conjugated secondary antibody or
detection
sometimes it's necessary to amplify your
signal for a low expressing
this is particularly particularly true
with the low expressing antigen or M or
if you want to anti-amplify over the
background
it's a two or three step protocol using
an antibody that is tagged with biotin
the biotin is then detected with evident
or related form and multiple
streptividine die conjugate will bind to
each antibody with high Affinity
increasing the number of time molecules
it's a commonly understood and
traditional method much brighter than a
standard secondary detection and low
abundance targets are more likely to be
detected
what are the disadvantage the
disadvantage is like longer protocol uh
you have to do a special blocking step
in between like endogene you have to
block endogenous Biotin and and it comes
with a greater potential for
non-specific binding
last is if the amplification is still
not enough and you need to amplify
further you can use the remedy and
Signal amplification kit it's a two or
three step process where an antibody is
stacked with hrp the hrp activates a Dye
label substrate which then binds to
residues around the site of the antigen
the die conjugated pyramidine substrate
with the hrp to covalently bind to
tyrosine residues around around the site
of hrp
this gives you the brightest signal it
is very useful with low abundance
targets and you can bring out the fine
structures in the tissue what are the
disadvantage increase protocol time you
have to do a special blocking with
endogenous peroxidase and it has a
greater potential for non-specific
binding
so just let's summarize the most
important points for for labeling
strategies the key of using
amplification technique is to have an
idea about the relative abundance of
your target for high expressing Target
is standard secondary detection is
enough or even even conjugate is usually
sufficient in
in fact in that cases if you use the TSA
kit it will over saturate your signal
for example in the in the image on the
right you can see if for the high
expressing tubulin if you use TSA or
streptoline it will over saturate the
signal while the labeled primary or
secondary antibody will will be the
right choice with the low expressing
targets like ketanine or something
if you try to use labeled primary or the
secondary antibody you will get no
signal while using streptividine or TSA
you will get the get appropriates
appropriate signals so make sure to
decide the right labeling strategy based
on your related Target abundance you
have to find the right balance
with every additional detection step you
increase you are increasing risk of
background due to indigenous components
non-specific protein binding or
non-specific die charge binding
with this background let's talk about
chlorophore colors available for your
Multiplex experiment
blue green orange red and deep Reds are
the are the more common colors
in floor sense we use different color
light lights to generate a fluorescent
this is called an called as an
excitation light the color you see is
the emitted light and you need to use a
different filter you need to use a
filter to filter out the unnecessary
lights and and different color need
different filters
you can also use dies near IR infra
wavelength for your Multiplex ISC
experiment like Alexa floor 750 die
Alexa 4 plus 800 or size 7 die but there
will be a significant bleed through if
you want to use the red or deep red
dries dies so it's not a good idea to
use a near IR die as a fourth color if
you if you are using red or deep red
also in your experiment
uh if you really want to do this thing
you need to have a special
multi-structural Imaging platform with
the spectral D convolution functionality
how you will decide the optimal
fluorophore and filter for your
experiment there are couple of rules
which you have to
keep in mind first know your instrument
limitation make sure to know about the
excitation source and detection filters
the die need to be matched to the
appropriate filters or light Cube it
could be the best die but if it could
not match with the excitation source and
detection filters of your instrument you
can't use that know your fluorophore
limitations like excitation and emission
expectra
uh extension coefficient is also very
very important this is the value that
indicates how well a fluorophore is
going to absorb lighter energy the
higher the extension coefficient the
better it is this is somehow related to
how bright a fluorophore is going to be
third is very important to know your
target is there any special overlap
between your targets are are you going
to uh doing a multiplex experiment with
the target located in the same sub
cellular compartment it's very important
you to know about that
last
uh use the fluorescent Spectra viewer to
Tool it will give you an idea about the
spectral overlap and bleed through
between the different floor of four
and you you are in the position to
choose the better fluorophore and die
combinations for your experiment for
example let's talk about the
the image on the right uh it's it's for
Alexa 488 which is a very common green
die in the purple color you in the blue
color you can see the excitation curve
of the die in the pink color you can see
the emission curve of the Alexa for 488
die if you have to choose the right
filters for Alexa floor 88 how you will
decide
so for our evos microscope we suggest uh
gfp gfp light cubes shown in the bottom
right why we suggest gfp light Cube as
you can see that light Cube excitation
bandwidth shown in purple and emission
bandwidth shown in red complete is
beautifully overlapping with the Alexa
floor 88 excitation and emission
emission curve so with you can use Alexa
gfp light live Cube confidently with
your Alexa 488 die
so if you are using a fluoresense die it
is important that dye should not overlap
spectrally so you can separate the
signal to help you choose the dyes that
are spectrally separated from your
various Aces we have online Spectra
viewer viewer tool you can enter a large
number of ties and see how they are
excitation and emission curves overlap
with each other
you can enter the specification of your
light cubes or filter set as well as
laser excitation wavelength to determine
if the sets that you have
is appropriately matching with the with
the dye in question
remember that careful diet choices means
clearly separated labels
for a multiplexing experiment it's very
important that dye should be
sufficiently separated in excitation and
emission to prevent bleed through
through the neighboring channels so in
the in the image on the right if you
have two fluorophores which are
separated beautifully spectrally you
don't have an issue but often this is
not possible often you have have a Dye
combination they they have some overlap
in between so how you can minimize the
bleed throw in this situation you can
use the corrective measures like you can
reduce the concentration of offending
the eye you can choose a different die
combination that is not spectrally
overlapping you can choose a different
filter option that has a narrower band
pass width
or you can use special imaging software
to subtract out one image for another in
a situation like like you if you have a
fluorophore which are almost identical
in that cases you need a special
spectral deconvolution instrument to
substitute certain wavelength signals
if you have done immunohistochemistry
before you must have noticed this photo
bleaching issues what happened that
under intense illumination of a
microscope flowsense dyes are prone for
photo bleaching is irreversible feeding
of the signals why this happened this
happened because of the poor diet
choices
some dyes are more prone for photo
bleaching it can happens because of the
intensity and time of Illumination the
more intense the illumination the faster
the flow to bleaching or formation of
free radicals or reactive oxygen species
exposure of dyes to a light can generate
free radicals or reactive and reactive
oxygen is particularly signalent oxygen
this can interact with dye molecule to
speed degradation
so how you can overcome the photo
bleaching issue they are there are a lot
of ways you can do that like choosing a
more stable tie if by any chance you
don't have an option of it choosing a
more stable die
you can choose more stable counter
stains like tapping to find focus and
Orient your Orient your stiff cells and
then switch over to the die which is
photo labile and take the image as quick
as possible reduce the laser power or
LED voltage
uh you can also reduce the time for
visualizing the sample by eyes before
capturing the image
use a lower power magnification
objectives or objective with the lower
numerical aperture to find your samples
and if you are doing confocal Imaging
you can reduce average number of scans
per line
make sure it's very important to store
your sample in darkness avoid them from
direct sunlight and to reduce the
problem issue of reactive oxygen species
or or the formation of free radical you
can use a mountain with a
um with a mounted with the capabilities
of antioxidant capabilities or free
radical scavenger
use a curing Mountain mounting media for
your immunohistochemistry experiment
what happened that hardening slows down
the moment of free radicals and Ros
make sure to keep the slides cold after
your after the curing uh
and you store them in the in a cold room
to avoid the free movement of free
radical scenaro Ros
to increase photo stability Thermo
fissure offer a wide varieties of photo
stable tiles like Alexa flow dies they
are very bright eyes they are photos
stable we have these dies matched to
Common filters and we also have a die
Alexa floor plus which are which are
more which are which is five times more
sensitive than traditional Alexa for
secondary antibodies as you can see in
the picture on the right Alex how bright
the Alexa flow plus as compared to
traditional Alexa floor dies
uh to minimize photo beaching of
experiment and samples we have developed
a series of anti-fed reagent that
increase fluoros fluorophore photo
stability in both lived and fixed cells
we offer like choice of immediate
Imaging uh or anti-fits for immediate
Imaging or for long term is for storage
and they also come with or without
without Debbie based on your
experimental need you can either or the
order get them with with happy or
without that Epi so
these are these are the exam you can on
the on the right you you can see an
example where we have done 60 second
time lapse showing the showing the
enhanced resistance of our prolonged
gold prolonged diamond and prolonged
glass over traditional mounting media
like glycerol with the glycerol the
photo bleaching is significantly higher
as compared to prolonged gold and
diamond and glass they they reduce photo
bleaching in the time course experiment
now let's talk about the importance of
controls in In a multiplexing experiment
they are very important part of
immunohistochemistry experiment but
often researchers does not realize its
importance if you are doing a
multiplexic experiment you should have
three main important controls the first
is auto fluoresense control in this
control you should you have no primary
or secondary or dies of any sort the
sample should be washed mountain in
image in a same way this will give you
an idea about the native Auto float
sense of your sample the second control
is no primary control this is to check
non-specific binding of the secondary
antibodies streptavidine or tiramidine
the sample should be washed mountain and
image in a say in a same way the third
control is no cross labeling control if
you are using multiple primary and
secondary it's uh you should
check the commercial source of cross
absorption
perform single color labeling with the
wrong pairs to make sure the antibody
does not
bind to the other specific other primary
antibodies
with this control the objective of using
these three control is is to it will
give you confidence and hopefully all
these controls are negative and then you
can uh use uh do your experiment with
confidence
another important aspect of
immunohistochemistry is counter stain
counter stains are chemical and flow
sense dye which are used to identify
Targets in combination with antibodies
they provide contrast of the primary
stain and can be cell structure is
specific they are very important to
orient sample during
immunohistochemistry experiment you
should perform counter staining in the
last and common counter stains are
nucleic acid counter stains and actin
cytoka skeleton skin like dappy your
photophotic phthalodine for actin scale
you can also use a click it Edo kits for
using proliferating cells as a counter
stain
these are some examples with the of the
account of the counter strains
in the last let's talk about just to
summarize I want to tell you about some
important rules to remember for your
Multiplex ISC experiments
for antibody fluoro floor plating it's
very important to pair the weakest
staining antibody with the brightest
flow for and pair the antibody with the
strongest labeling and the most abundant
Target expression with the weakest
available fluorophone in that way you
can find the right balance
the second thing is how you can overcome
epitope masking epitope masking is
another factor that can add complexity
for achieving accurate staining when you
are performing multiplexing epitome
masking can occur when you have a
multiple
antibodies which are directed against
epitose located in the same subcellular
compartments of the same cells in a
tissue for example like if you are using
TSA amplification a thyramidine is
deposit over the first such epitope uh
and it can blanket nearby pitos that you
are trying to stain later so there are
approaches in which you can
overcome this issue of epitope masking
like titration of secondary antibody
titration of therapidine fluorophore
complexes
you can you should optimize the
incubation time for both the secondary
and thyramidine fluorophore complex
make sure to choose fluorophore based on
target abundance check the spectral
overlap check instrument excitation and
emission filter and very important don't
over excite your fluorophores
thanks
thank you darpan for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
now let's get started
our first question here is how can you
determine whether you need to adjust the
concentration of your primary or
secondary antibody
okay this is very good question yeah for
every expert every time if you are
trying to do any antibody for the first
time it's it's better to uh to adjust
the concentration of primary and
secondary antibody if you don't do that
it will lead to over saturation of
signal or either you will get no signal
so suppose the manufacturer recommended
concentration of 1 to 200 for the
primary antibody I will recommend you to
try two or three different concentration
like one two hundred one to two hundred
or more like one to three hundred and
see in which which concentration you are
getting the best staining where the
signal to noise ratio is minimal you are
doing a nuclear staining and you are
getting a nuclear signal not the
cytoplasmic staining if you are doing a
cytoplasmic straining you are not
getting anything in the nucleus so that
that's why it's very important to
determine the primary antibody
concentration for sex similarly with the
secondary antibody it's important to
have the right bank balance if you use
too much a secondary antibody it will
give you non-specific binding so make
sure to have the secondary antibody
concentration also optimize similarly as
the primary antibody concentration
okay thank you for that another question
here are there any tips for mounting the
slide and can you use too much mounting
media
yeah so it's very important to mount
slide very Pro very properly don't use
too much mounting media don't use two
less mounting media it should be like
for a if you have a suppose Mouse spring
section one or two drops will be enough
to it should be like enough to cover the
section and when you are putting your
cover slip on the put in a slight angle
and drop it slowly as slow slow as
possible so that it does not create air
bubbles in it because if the if your
tissue has air bubbles you it will your
whole immunohistochemistry experiment
will be no use because you have too much
bubbles in the tissue
thank you
um next question here when
permeabilizing tissue should your
detergent be in the wash solution
blocking buffer or antibody dilute
dilute or both
for formalization before I would
recommend your uh you can have like a
lower concentration of detergents like
try like 2020 in your wash buffer but I
will not recommend to use uh any
detergent in your antibody dilution
steps it should only be in the
formalization buffer in your not in the
antibody dilution buffers
thank you lots of great questions coming
in here
um our next one do you have any
recommended methods for antibody
stripping and how much loss do we expect
between cycles and how many times can
you do it
yeah my recommendation for antibodies
tripping it you can you can start with
like a heat hit induce anti-generative
table step first start with it like
because there will always always going
to be a tissue loss or more you will do
more cycles of heat and induce antigen
retrieval you will do and start with
like some mild buffer with a less peers
like citrate buffer with ps6 don't go
with the higher pH of citrate buffer and
if you don't if you have if you are
using your in-house reagents I will
recommend maximum two cycles of strip
not more than that because you will
definitely going to lose lot of tissue
around around it and there will be
always going to be some antibody left
okay thank you next question here
um how long do slides need to be left to
dry before Imaging
yeah so my recommendation is like
after mounting left you leave your slide
at the room temperature in the dark for
like six to eight hours after that the
best way is like to keep the slides
stored in a cold room now I will not
recommend more than eight hours leaving
the slides in the room temperature
thank you another question what is the
key thing to follow in multiplexing if
the spatial location of the two antigens
is the same
yeah that's a very good question for if
you are doing a multiple multiplexing
and your G your target is on the same
sub Cellular location uh you you should
know the abundance of the target try to
have your target which is like highly
expressing pair with the fluorophore
which is the weakest and and the target
which is low expressing pair with the
fluorophore which is bright which is
more brighter and use the use the use
the different concentration of
fluorophores of fluorophy dilutions also
to get the right balance
foreign
lots of questions still and then let's
see um another person's asking what are
the major differences between different
ways of blocking and any particular
considerations
yeah so there are like different
blocking people you see them for
blocking people use the
so main consideration for blocking is
that what you are trying to do like if
you are using like a go antibody which
is raised in a goat so and you want to
do a multiplexing then use the go to
serum as a blocking reagent if you are
using antibody which is raised in a
donkey use the donkey and for it and if
you are doing a multiplexing experiment
where you have different combinations of
mice antibody and you want to use on a
mice tissue then then use the mouse
blocking blocking reagent so it depends
on what you are trying to achieve and
what primary and secondary antibodies
combinations you are using uh that it
then you can decide that this is the
appropriate blocking agent and for and
also I can mention that if you can use
like uh FPS or something and make sure
to try different blocking regions see
see where you are getting low signal to
noise ratio
thank you for that
another question
can you talk about how the prolonged
Mountain compares to DPX in terms of
fade prevention your example mentioned
uh glycerol
I uh unfortunately I'm not familiar of
DPS
I have always used prolonged mountain
and what based on my experience with the
immunohistochemistry I have seen the the
tissue which are you mounted with
prolonged gold they are good for months
I I had even used the prolonged gold
mounted tissue after two years and the
fluorescence was maintained I have no
idea about the DPS mounting media
thank you Tarpin
um the next question do you have any
tips on how to have successful antigen
retrieval for brain slices which one is
better heating or enzymatic treatment
yeah so he depends on what you are
trying to do if you if your brain tissue
the if it's like you are using your
tissue who has like injured injury
tissues then anti-generity will
sometimes become very harsh because you
are going to lose tissue around the
injury side like if you are using using
multiple sclerosis models there is a
lesion around it and you will lose the
tissue then antigen retrieval will be
harsh but if you have a overly fixed
tissue then proteinase K treatment will
be protein in statement will be the best
treatment because it will break the
methyl Bridge which is formed by the
formaline
if you want to if you are not getting
any any straining and you want to try
anti-generate travel I will suggest you
try for like a lower time first like try
for a for a 10 minutes don't over boil
that issue and take out the tissue out
from the from the boiling media and make
sure to teach you to dry like cold cold
now instead of just putting the reagent
or a washing buffer on it otherwise you
will break the tissue around the injury
side
great thank you and a related question
do we need antigen retrieval stuff for
Frozen tissue
yes if you are trying to stain like a
antigen which are intracellular which
are where they are in the intercellular
compartment it's better to use the
antigen retrieval step because you want
your your antibody to reach to the
internally so in that case I will
recommend to use the antigen retrieval
on the Frozen tissue I have personally
used that and there I find it works
beautifully and you will give you a
crisp crisp staining
thank you I believe you might have
already spoken on this but should the
slide be very dry before putting
mounting media
no I I will not if you if you are using
uh fresh of like a Frozen tissue slides
should not be very dry otherwise uh you
will find it very difficult to do
staining future so if you are using our
Pro long gold or prolong any prolonged
mounted there there is no need of drying
the slide you just have to remove the
access buffer from the tissue and just
put the mounting media and mount the
slides
thank you another question here what are
the key differences to completing
immunofluorescent staining in a
well-plate and honest slide
foreign
if you are doing on a plate or you are
doing on your tissue is that the there
will be difference in the antigen
retrieval and permalization buff because
if you are working on a honest on a
cells you don't want to do very harsh
antigen retrieval or primalization
instead you can't use very like the
concentration of formalization buffer
between 20 and Triton X will be very
Less in the in with the cell as compared
to the tissues so that's the major major
difference it comes
thank you have time for a few more
questions
um do you recommend using BSA along with
serum
uh BSA along with serum yes you in in
some cases you you can't combine them
together and use it uh depend if if you
are getting lot of unspecific staining
and you think that it's it's not
sufficient you can combine them together
like 2.5 percent of BSA and 2.5 percent
of serum uh and then just try it and see
it's your signal to noise ratio is
better with the combination or not
thank you and someone is saying you
mentioned starting with the
concentration that is mentioned in the
protocol for primary a b so when we are
titrating what concentrations above and
below the recommended concentrations
would you suggest
yeah so suppose the it's recommended to
use 1 200 concentration what I will do I
will try three or four different
concentration I like I will use a pep
pen and we may make it uh make a barrier
around my second my four sections on a
slide and I will create one 250 on one
one two hundred on second one to two
hundred on Third and one to three
hundred like three or four common
combination on the same slide and I can
see side by side which one is giving me
better signal and which is the most
reliable one
great another question fro researchers
who are new to IHC what would be the
most common mistake that can easily be
avoided
yeah sometime I have I have my
experience that most common mistake
people do that they don't realize the
importance of each and every step of
immunohistochemistry like sometimes they
take very lightly with the washing step
like oh it's recommended five minute
free washing what happen if I will do
three and a half minute of three washing
it's fine it matters if you do earn if
the washing is not appropriate if you do
incomplete washing what will happen that
it will lead to a lot of background in
your tissue in your staining so washing
is the thing which I have noticed with
several researchers they they take it
very lightly oh just it's fine just
washing but washing should be very
critical another thing I have noticed
they don't realize that
the concentration of antibodies and the
and the incubation time also matter you
you can't have like oh adding more does
not give you the better signal so it
should be the appropriate concentration
and don't over bleach the tissue no
don't over excite the tissue because
then that case is also they just float
to bleach the tissues
thank you
our next question here is do you think
it is mandatory to use normal IGG as a
control of primary antibody if so please
leave tips
it's not mandatory it depends on your
what you want to do by basically I I
never use it so it's up to you if you
want to use it in a normal IGG as a
control you you can use it but it's it's
not mandatory
thank you
another question here and there are
protocols using only a PB phosphate
buffer throughout and one's using PB and
PBS phosphate buffered saline there that
are used differently for washing and
antibody staining steps does this
distinction matter
uh I don't know they are basically the
either you use phosphate buffer or
phosphate but for Saline they basically
are the same so there's there's no
difference between the uh it does not
matter whatever you are using for your
experiment
awesome
couple more here do you recommend beta
gonna have trouble pronouncing this
um
for a B stripping
I have personally had never used beta my
captain ethanol for antibodies training
I have used for it for Western and it
works perfectly for for
immunostochemistry experiments uh I have
not used it so I I can't suggest if you
want I can dig into the literature and
get back to you after the webinar that
people have used it or not I personally
did not use it for immunoster chemistry
experiments
thank you
um and then someone is wondering uh
which hematoxylin is good mares or Gill
hematoxin
actually I have no idea about that I
have not used hematoxylene and so I have
to look into it
thank you
um what is your take on universal
antigen retrieval buffers do they work
better than citrate or other specific pH
retrieval buffers
yeah Universal buffers also work very
beautifully I have personally used
commercial buffers from different
vendors and they they work similarly as
the as if you have making citrate buffer
in the lab or you are purchasing it from
they basically work fine and with more
efficiency as compared to the in-house
made reagents which you are making like
because there should be different
between the composition of the uh they
have different of the water you use the
ph and those type of things if you use
the commercial one the pH is guaranteed
and the best quality reagents are used
so I have used it before and it works
good
thank you as a blocking solution how
much is the percentage of serum
concentration recommended and is there
any High concentration serum effect
uh mainly I recommended I prefer to use
between two to five percent of serum
concentration sometime uh sometimes
people use more concentration or it will
be good for one particular Target but
it's not going too good for your
Multiplex experiment because it will it
will create unnecessary your antibodies
will not bind because of the access
serum so what I will suggest that if you
are doing a multiplexing experiment try
two to five percent not going more than
that otherwise you will get one antigen
work beautifully and other are not
working because of the overuse of serum
great thank you um someone is wondering
um how can we reduce the overlap of
fluorescent
so
it's something like for overlap of
fluorescence like use this Spectra we
were to Tool and see that how they are
where they are uh are they overlapping
how much some overlap is always going to
be the but if it's a too much of a
overlap it's not a good idea to use that
and you for the duplex essay you you can
use like use the far red and the green
and so that they cannot bleed into each
other but there should be always you
should always be careful about the with
this there is spectra uh use the lower
concentration use the lower incubation
time for the prime for the secondary
antibodies and dioxide and the
exposure when you're taking doing the
Imaging reduce the exposure time so that
bleed through should be less
thank you
um another question related to drying
how much do you need to dry the tissue
in the slide after each wash step
uh I will recommend there is no need to
excessively dry the tissue just remove
the excess excess liquid out from the
from the slide uh but there is like what
I personally prefer that I I just use my
hands and flick it and so that all the
excess liquid comes down that's much
drying is required not more than that
thank you
um someone was wondering we see a Blues
Haze intermittent on our tissue sections
after cover slipping is there a way to
prevent this we use
dapi for nuclear staining and changing
concentrations of that and it did not
make any difference
so what does my question will be for you
that what concentration of dappy you are
using may try to reduce the
concentration of the tapi maybe you are
using too much of a dappy and maybe
induce like one one additional washing
step before mounting the tissue maybe
it's not possible that too much of a
dappy is around us tissue and that's why
you are getting the haze so a two point
reduce the concentration of the adapting
and then second uh inducer
have one washing step in between the
mounting
you I'm just a reminder any questions we
don't get to
um we will follow up after this is over
um I will truly end with a few more here
and we have a few more minutes so is it
possible to perform multiplexing
staining with amplification using floor
four conjugated abedin
yeah yeah you you can you can do that
there's it should be no no problem that
you can do multiplexing with using
fluorophore conjugated evidence make
sure that uh do sequentially don't try
to do all all three or four multiplexing
antibodies together do in a sequential
manner so that in that case you can do
it
okay thank you we'll wrap with this one
avoiding heating for antigen retrieval
would you like to recommend any antigen
retrieval buffer or any methods or
technique
so
sometimes it's very important to do the
anti-gender retrieval there is no choice
you are not getting any any staining and
you have to do it so in that case what I
will suggest you to try if you are using
a citrate buffer try to do the use the
lower pH of citrate buffer instead of
using ph9 use the PS with the pH 9 you
will get the right signals but uh there
will be a tissue damage also so I will
recommend lower pH of citrate buffer and
what I have personally seen that if you
if you if you are not worried about your
tissue loss do the antigen retrieval for
10 minutes take the slide out and put in
the ice cold uh PBS
you will get a very crisp signals but
opposite happen if you have a tissue
where which is like a damaged tissue
where you have a chances of losing that
issue if you do that there will be
tissue loss so if you are using a
perfect brain brain section do the
antigen retrieval wash your tissue
immediately with the cold PBS and get
the crisp training
great thank you thank you again so much
darpan for your time today and your
important research we'd like to also
thank labroots and our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcasts before we
go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for all their
interesting questions any questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with any one of
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you